hey ladies do you like your men the
strong and silent type that can rip a
man's head off and throw it about like a
basketball
you do well have we got a treat for you
throughout this video we're going to be
discussing one of the boys most eligible
bachelors
black noir this video will be covering
his true identity in the comics
or theories for the show and a lot more
that will make you want to dump your
favorite breast milk drinking man at
home
lander i'll stop doing that voice now
look obviously there will be heavy
spoilers here
so if you don't want anything about the
comics or potentially the show ruined
then i recommend that you turn off now
up top we will be spoiling one of the
biggest twists in the source material
and whilst i don't think this will be
carried across to the show it may well
be
so yeah this is your last chance to back
out without the way
i'm your host definition aka the guy
that's also tall dark and handsome
according to my mother now let's get
into the breakdown
okay so black noir is one of the most
mysterious characters in the boys
very little is actually known about him
as far as the comics go
and there's even less when it comes to
the show however in the source material
it's actually revealed that the
character is in fact a clone of
homelander
and we discover that he was created as a
contingency plan by
vort in case he ever went rogue in both
the show and comic
he initially hides a lot of his powers
such as his heat vision
flight abilities and super speed but the
character is capable of all of these
even though on the surface he sort of
just seems like capacitive batman
however that is precisely what makes him
so good
and why the character goes undetected
for so long he very much fools
homelander into believing that he only
has one power set
when really he has exactly the same
black noir operates so well
because very little is actually known
about him in episode 4 of the second
season
homelander even remarks that the
character doesn't have a race
showing that he's never even seen his
face we never hear him speak either
and though i'm sure he has a lovely
singing voice to match his skills on the
piano
he's kept himself to himself to avoid
any suspicion at all
black noir is very much fort's lap dog
and he does
exactly what the company tell him to
without question
the show has designed him to look very
much like black jason voorhees
to hammer home that he's pretty much
just a machine that goes wherever they
tell him to
black noir is a soulless unfeeling
monster
that is pretty much that a thing that
clive owen was trying to create in
gemini man
which spoiler alert now focusing on his
comic book story
in the original work black noir was so
used to completing missions
that this eventually led to his downfall
after he failed one he slowly started to
go insane
and over time dressed as homelander he
began to commit various crimes that
involve cannibalism
murder and sexual assault in the comics
it was actually revealed that it was
black noir who was behind what happened
to butch's wife becker
and not homelander this sparked up a lot
of this story in the comics
and gave the boys more motive to kill
homelander which ultimately led to
homelander fighting back
black noir also blackmailed homelander
and though he was initially upset over
having no memory of the horrific events
it eventually empowered him to believe
that he could do whatever he wanted to
the situation escalated and thus black
noir was complicit in homelanders
downfall
making him the true big bad of the
comics when homelanders started the
superhero uprising
he slowly went on a rampage that
involved murdering the president
billy rushed to the oval office to stop
him and it's at this point that black
noir revealed himself
and his true identity homelander lost it
and realized he could have been a real
hero if he'd not be manipulated by vote
noir
and he tried to kill noir however he was
no pushover
and he actually killed homelander with
his bare hands
luckily homelander had managed to
severely weaken noir to the point that
billy was able to step in
and using a crowbar here he completely
butchered
butchered the character now the show
could be going in this direction
but i think it's already hinted to the
audience that it's not
now the main reason that i don't think
that the television counterpart will
follow this course
is because in the comic book community
the twist is so well known at this point
that
there's little to no chance that it
won't be ruined for for the general
audience
if the show goes on say for five seasons
there's still three more years in which
most of the show's audience will either
find out through google
or by watching idiotic youtubers like
myself ruin it
so i really think that they'll be trying
something different when it comes to his
reveal
and the show has already sort of teased
this now in the comic books
homelander says that noir is the person
that he's known the longest
and this is obviously the case because
he's a clone of the character
however in the series we learn that it's
actually made and because of their age
and the way people are drafted into the
seven it's unlikely that this would have
been his whole life
at best i'd say even if homelander was
drafted into the seven in his twenties
then he's only known may for about 10
years and therefore
he's known or even less it's difficult
to get the dates
exactly right as we don't know the exact
ages of the characters
but it doesn't seem likely that they've
known each other that long
we also see in the opening of the second
season that black noir is badly burned
when hunting super terrorists
and if he really was a clone of
homelander then this wouldn't have left
a scratch on him as he's pretty much
invincible
saying all that though i would love it
if we learned that some of the versions
of homelander that we've seen in the
show
weren't actually him and there are a
couple of times where the breast milking
could be tightened war and is almost
maybe like personality
i doubt it though because who doesn't
love a nice drink of
mother's milk what now edgar also talks
down to homelander quite a lot
and surely he would only do this if he
knew he had a contingency plan in place
noir is pretty much edgar's lap dog and
will do whatever he says
so i think this could highlight that he
has made a duplicate
the official boys twitter account also
posted a photo of the group with some
some weird is that jack from jupiter
so sorry you got got a bit sidetracked
there anyway they posted this photo
and if you look closely you can see that
homelander and black noir
are actually holding the exact same
stance in pose
this is a very very minor detail but the
fact that they're doing this
can actually confirm that they are
indeed identical
or maybe not now if he isn't a clone of
homelander
then who else could he be now we do know
that actor nathan mitchell is playing
noir in the show
but i believe that this is a stand-in
until they cast someone
however jeffrey dean morgan has also
been cast in an unknown role in the
upcoming third season
and though as of now we know little
about who he's playing
i would actually love to see him reveal
this noir from his portrayal of negan
and the walking dead
we know he can pull off this slightly
insane side of any character
and i think it would be great if he was
revealed under the mask as the villain
though that might not be the case i
would love it if it is
but i also have another theory that he's
actually a clone of billy butcher
now why exactly would this be well we
know from the comics that billy's
relationship with the cia
goes way back and that he'd had several
run-ins with the seven
over the years the show could easily
build upon this
and make it so that vogt were aware of
just how good he was at fighting supes
and thus they decided to build the
ultimate 7 contingency plan
made from someone who shared an
unrivaled hate for the group
i think it would be great if it was
revealed that the corporation cloned
billy
and then injected the clone with
compound v if they gave the clone the
right stimulus
it could grow up to hate the seven just
as much as billy does
and it would also make it so that if it
ever came down to it
that billy would be facing a mirror
image of himself which
psychologically could completely
blindside him
now why this would also be interesting
is because if they tied things in with
the comics
and made it so that it was actually noir
that sexually assaulted becca
then technically ryan would be made from
billy's dna
and thus on some levels it would
actually be his son
this would allow him to potentially get
over the idea of dumping him
which is something that he struggled
with in episode 4.
again this could be a reach but i'd
absolutely love to see that as the
reveal
other theories are that it's a clone of
edgar and
which i don't believe and then it could
also just be the superpowered babies
injected with growth hormones
we never see noise face so he would be
easy to replace with one of these if
anything bad ever happened to him
and vort do have a steady supply again i
don't know if that's
true or not but anyway it's gonna be
unlikely that we'll ever find out who he
is
until the show tells us for definite but
i'd of course
love to hear your thoughts on his
identity in the comments if you enjoyed
this video then please drop a thumbs up
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the fourth episode which is going to be
linked at the end
we go over all the easter eggs and
things you missed
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more we're also giving
away a free copy of the christopher
nolan collection at the end of the month
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and drop a
comment below if you want to support us
so that videos like this can get made
then please consider clicking the join
button below you can also come chat news
on our discord server linked in the
description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been
definition and i'll see you next time
take care peace
you